[Music]
thank you
hanging your laundry in the freezing
cold your clothes are just gonna freeze
when you bring them into thaw they'll be
wet again who does Mrs Claus have to
sleep with to get a hand pressed for
Christmas how do I know so much about
Santa well I'm Mrs Claus why are you
acting like I was the one asking
questions do
the person Mrs Claus it was long ago
before you were living assuming you know
your audience's age for all you know I
could be a baby boomer and use Facebook
and say things like here comes trouble
when I see my friend at Applebee's and
then gripe about how those damn
Millennials in their YouTubes and
avocado toast are ruin and everything no
I can't give you the very date
unreliable narration rapid presents and
ribbons and gauze has Ward be weary said
Santa Claus yeah we know who's talking
Mrs C we're right here stop justifying
your Nursery School rhyme scheme by
telling us things we already know that
is sort of kind of Kink inside whatever
I think of
that Christmas ride whoa hold on Sienna
there's a time and place to discuss your
kinks in the beginning of a children's
cartoony one of them at least that's
what a federal judge explained to me a
few years back when I got this ankle
monitor probably never got over the case
of near pneumonia you picked up last
year how do you catch a case of near
pneumonia does that work for other
illnesses too can you have mere yellow
fever or near bronchitis did you get a
near medical degree for these diagnoses
why there'd be no Christmas well that's
not exactly true Mrs Claus the day would
still exist people could still celebrate
with their families go to church eat
food the only thing they'd be missing
are presents that magically appear under
the tree hell those polar bears could
even still drink Coca-Cola Without Santa
nobody cares about Christmas anymore
that's not what the angry man on Fox
News told me important people tell the
papers I'm much too tired for Christmas
Capers for someone that's this tired
Santa will sure go on to do a lot of
rhyming before this is all over also
does Santa regularly make announcements
in the newspaper does he write op-eds
about holidays to announce his Christmas
plans if so which ones or is Santa
syndicated under a pseudonym now I had a
suspicion about those hairy jingle balls
articles and now I'm sure Santa was
taking a holiday and the world would
soon know that it was to be The Year
Without a Santa Claus roll claws
Marshalls calendar is clear enough to
let me know this story likely takes
place in 1953 1959 or 1970 but not clear
enough to let me know what month it is
after January now more interested in the
story of this guy who not only painted
the movie title on his buggy but a
copyright year and production company
feeling my best why not just get someone
else to be Santa for a year can't you
just call up one of your Replacements
like Tim Allen or Bender why do you have
to shut down the whole operation just
because you don't want it this year let
an elf be Santa or your wife honestly
this decision is seeming a bit elphist
and sexist the more I think about it Mrs
Claus is singing about how the children
thought Santa died and we're all sad
about it right before the TV movie shows
us that his resignation was big news and
then spends half the run time on the
fact that none of the kids really cared
[Music]
this tear is not blue and I'm scream why
is one humming wait I'm still confused
about how Santa disseminated this
announcement to the Press did he fax
every newspaper a press release from his
elves and the journalist whose job it is
to ask questions just went with the
announcement without asking for proof
whatever happened to journalistic
standards printing the same exact Daily
Tribune with two different headlines may
have been possible but it's certainly
not cost effective and might explain The
Disappearance of print media cried the
Gnomes and elves since when did the
North Pole hire gnomes never once before
in A Christmas Story have I heard
anything about gnomes who else works at
the North Pole Dragonborn to baxi will
you stop that trying to three stooge
with only two stooges oh hi Mrs Claus
yes Mrs Claus oh okay Mrs Claus sure
thing Mrs Claus we will never find out
the cause of all this claws Who would
know the difference just stand close
I mean the elves and gnomes would
probably notice reindeer as well and
since the newspapers know saying exists
now they'll probably have reporter
stationed at every chimney they can find
but other than the worldwide Global
media yeah nobody else would know I
admit I'm under fed but with a pillow
from the bed Santa's credibility is
based solely on the shape of his abdomen
cliche Mrs Claus is now singing about
going down the chimney with Santa sack
and even if that wasn't meant to be a
euphemism it certainly won now Mrs
clausie is now singing about only being
seen from the back and presenting to the
camera I'm making getting a question if
this was a song about taking up the
mantle of Santa Claus or her desire to
start at only fans
writers continue to provide evidence for
my previous argument well I guess we'll
have to move right on then to plan B
that's it you made me sit through an
entire song about your taking Santa's
place and you just give up just like
that I haven't seen something this
pointless since Finn and Rose took a
holiday the Canto bite writing a vixen
asked to ask as part of Plan B also why
are you forcing poor Vixen to carry two
fully grown elves you showed us a team
of reindeer earlier that clearly aren't
being used let them take the sleigh Mrs
Claus is a dick to reindeer concern it
Ma what's going on using the phrase
consarn it only Joe Pesci could get away
with using such a ridiculous phrase in
place of cursing then he'd have to be
robbing a McAllister family home first
she's just a baby earlier Mrs Claus said
vixen had been out in the world before
so she could just show jingle and jingle
around now Santa's saying she's just a
baby we know vixen's a regular member of
the team that pulls the sleigh so either
San is using a baby reindeer to fly his
sleigh or she's not so young that Mrs
Claus should be in trouble for sending
her out this devil of a brother will put
the heat on on them for sure so there
are two brothers with ice and fire
powers that regularly try to stop Santa
from delivering toys and Mrs Claus and a
couple defenseless elves and a baby
reindeer out while forgetting this yo
I'm starting to think Mrs Claus is the
villain in this story she was gonna be
Santa this year then probably remembered
those brothers and Cynthia's to die in
her place
why do you guys keep using using a
reindeer to carry fully grown people it
normally takes a team of eight to pull
sand in his sleigh you're killing these
poor creatures Snow Miser who controls
the northern part of the world trying to
turn everything to icicles and his nasty
brother trying to keep the South so hot
with narrative snowflake a year this
either spits in the face of a very icy
South Pole or Mrs Claus has unknowingly
created a third option for voters who
aren't quite on board with the flat
earthers or the ball earthers riding a
vixen the wrong way on a one-way Street
even if that wasn't meant to be a
euphemism it's certainly won now pick
your socks off take my socks off just
always you're told Quentin tarantinoing
someone without explicit consent also
these red and black socks are magically
Brown on the inside which shouldn't
really make a difference because putting
socks on a reindeer's head is a terrible
disguise that only works because the
writers willed it to Buck for the lady
Rover
what the [ __ ] how and why is this woman
using a cat for a hand warmer when
everyone will continually say that South
Town is hot year round that hurt a whole
bunch of children over there well let's
talk to them going to add that to the
list of things two dudes named jingle
and jangle should never say in public
okay the cat's no longer the scariest
part of the movie this child is I'm more
scared of that kid than I was of
anything in The Conjuring films besides
believing in Santa Clauses for little
kids but you read about Christmas being
canceled in the newspaper right all of
those stories written by adults mention
the holiday being canceled the second
newspaper again run by adults even had a
freaking picture of Santa sick in bed so
I'm pretty sure believing in Santa Claus
should be for everyone because he's
clearly an observable phenomenon if I
were you guys I wouldn't waste my time
worrying about Santa Claus you got a
bigger Problem Iggy is a dick and the
cause of all the drama surrounding
whether or not Vixen will live or die
all because being a lead-bearing wise
ass was more important than alerting J J
to the problem while there was still
time to intervene a very nice boy
Ignatius thistle white he is not nice
name too it is not can you spare a
moment sure my name's Ignatius thistle
white why not just give him your social
security number as well kids don't talk
to strangers especially not once
creeping out from behind trees well why
did you bring him inside and talk you
just heard this man sneeze loud enough
that it caught your attention from
inside the house and you want to bring
him inside to spend more time with your
ill-named son man pre-covered really was
a different time
this priest sneezes on for all the
sometime Iggy's father is now singing
about how he believes in Santa Claus
because he once awoke to Santa standing
over his bed and somehow this was a good
thing poor little vixen so frightened
and sick in the dog pound TV movie wants
me to believe that a person who spends
all day with dogs can't tell the
difference between one and a reindeer
with antler condoms and his friends must
be real elves and their dog I'll bet
that dog was a baby reindeer writers
expedite the plot by having this child
detective all the pieces together based
on his witnessing of one Supernatural
event tell him the whole story oh yes
because if there's one thing I know
about Mayors it's that they're eager to
make time for kids to tell them stories
about Santa I'm sure he'll get right in
without any issues I'll spring your uh
reindeer from the hoose cow who's cow
what the [ __ ] is a who's gal ah hang on
all right let's see
oh here it is huskow a western U.S slang
term meaning prison comes from the
Spanish husgado a word for court or
tribunal all right that checks out but
I'm still sending you for making me get
the dictionary out do you know how heavy
this dictionary is it's really heavy
I'll call all the Mayors in the U.S of a
will give Santa an official national
holiday this year I doubt Mayors have
this kind of power but more importantly
I doubt he has all their phone numbers
also the mayor is essentially holding a
reindeer hostage in a grand scheme to
induce climate change this is at minimum
and abusive power the mayor's now
singing about how it's going to snow but
the bet he placed with the elves was
based on his disbelief that they were in
fact elves so why is running out into
the streets thinking about how it's
going to snow the very first thing he
does
dude I'm not sure things being white
enough was ever the problem of this
cartoon this chaplain Cameo never pays
off if he didn't get Vixen back to the
North Pole fast
well who knows what might happen to the
littlest reindeer of the team death
you're talking about dead reindeer so
please stop dashing dancing and prancing
around the issue as far as they knew
Vixen was still in the pound wait a
second Iggy saw Santa fly off towards
the dog pound moments after he said
vixen got picked up by the dog catcher
so he should definitely know that Santa
was on the case and that he might have
solved this already and despite what the
production team wants you to think no
amount of camera panning is going to
change that also writers never tell us
the story of when jingle spent a few
months touring with Flava Flav you're
now forcing poor Blitz in to pull four
people in a sleigh all alone is there a
rule that you can only check out one
reindeer from the North Pole at a time
or did the animators just not want to
create multiple reindeer for these shots
Mr White Christmas I'm Mr snow I'm Mr
ice which is it so far you've given us
three different names and Mrs Claus
called you Snow Miser I'm beginning to
think that you can't be trusted we'll
have a blizzard nice try Mr icicle or
whatever your name is but although Dairy
Queen existed in 1974 when this film was
released it's iconic blizzard treats
weren't introduced for another decade so
here's a sin for offering Santa a snack
that doesn't even exist yet Heat Miser
just rhymed degrees with degrees that's
really all you need to know about that
him out of here well technically he's
not actually there his face is just
still on the zoom call which exists for
some reason in 1974. what does a flaming
fool want this time this might have been
more about the pun than being homophobic
but combined with the Tutti Frutti snow
cone dig from his brother earlier the
references are quickly moving from
veiled to sinnable
how are you shooting elements at each
other through a video screen is this
actually a portal explain this dark
magical dark Lords of the thermostat Mrs
C is through fooling around admitting
the two-thirds of this movie has been
foreplay and not the good kind
that's all two minutes ago Mrs Claus
said Mother Nature didn't like to be
disturbed and everyone was terrified of
her but when we cut to their
conversation she not only heard what
they had to say but brought out tea and
fruit as well why were they so terrified
of her was it to manufacture false
tension I think it was to manufacture
false tension
male legal holiday for Santa
why
law that said Santa had to do Christmas
every year what does this actually
accomplish do they even have that
Authority and how many mayors agreed to
this do you know how many cities there
are in the U.S alone more than 108 000
you're telling me the mayor of South
Town had enough time in a single day to
call every mayor and get them to push
this policy what if they didn't even
believe in Santa how did he convince him
is this special over yet also how long
was Santa napping that Mrs Claus and
jingle had enough time to wait for
newspapers to find out about the holiday
write about it and then send the paper
to print this article is featured in two
different papers and one of them ran it
twice and for some reason the writers
didn't think a menagerie breaking loose
was more interesting than watching Santa
cry about not being the center of
attention and get this
day off for Santa sure they offer Santa
makes sense and the thing about guns no
surprise there but Cleveland leading the
way fake news there is some good will in
the hearts of all men at this time of
year this especially this proves it oh
[ __ ] off Santa and the culturally biased
sled you wrote in on Japanese don't have
anything to prove to you fast as a
hurricane children hurled the happy
message around the world ah yes children
the fastest form of communication much
faster than the public media outlets and
governments that have already been well
established in this story just saying
why didn't the mayor just call up all
the mayors of the world they charted
buses and special trains to reach the
pole by the 24th was all their goals
expecting me to believe that all these
little [ __ ] were in this much of a
rush to pledge fealty to the King of the
North why is everybody standing around
there's work to be done because you told
them all to stop working and put covers
on everything for some reason it's
impossible to keep up with your wild
mood swings but what about your gout
when the [ __ ] did he have gout why are
they introducing third act ailments now
pile all those toys inside what toys
Santa you shut down production some time
ago why are you expecting that toys are
just there to be piled inside you should
have little to no product to ship so
unless he's about to re-gift all the
presents the children sent this working
is all the [ __ ] there's no time to
waste tonight
we ride what the [ __ ] Santa we spent
this whole movie trying to get you a
holiday and then when the kids finally
agree and send you gifts you suddenly
feel well enough to go christmasing
again what was the point of this entire
holiday special to make Santa look like
one of those people who loudly announced
they're quitting Facebook and then you
just lurk for about a week before
jumping back in with your thoughts on
gas prices if the world would stop
turning on its axis if people didn't
know your opinion Aunt Susan I mean
Santa
somehow Santa Claus always comes tagline
for Mrs Claus's new only fans page
somehow makes it into this craft
look like you're not up to anything
you're up to something
that doesn't make sense
who controls the northern part of the
world trying to turn everything to
ourselves so hot with an area snowflake
a year they're gonna call his dream The
Song of Ice and Fire Like a Virgin is
not about some sensitive girl who needs
a nice fella that's what true blue is
about no granted no argument about that
we're here on a special Mission we're on
a mission from God I had a couple Red
Bulls you ever had a Red Bull I never
had a Red Bull before but I had a Red
Bull last night I really like Red Bull
we wear our bathing drive a sand buggy